when Josephine Peter left her hometown
in South Africa it wasn't supposed to be
forever when she took a job as a nurse
in a British hospital she told her loved
ones she was planning to return but
kovat 19 has taken mrs. Peters life and
her dream and it's left an African
family brokenhearted do you have moments
where you regret the fact that your
mother was a nurse in Britain because
why was that she was helping other
people they loved her she was amazing
what was she like what kind of she was
amazing she loves me like and it was
evident that she loved me so much mrs.
Peter worked and died at Southport
Hospital in Merseyside and she was
honoured by her colleagues after her
death but her daughter Boulais and her
family in South Africa have not been
able to participate or mark for passing
do you remember the last time you spoke
to her okay do you remember what you
talked about it was a rough situation
because that's what we found out she
wasn't I see you Josephine came to
Britain in 2002 and moved the family
into a house next to Heathrow Airport
she would give 18 years to the NHS as a
nurse and a midwife but she made a big
decision on her last trip home when was
the last time she was here in January in
January okay we just come back from a
family honeymoon and I think she enjoyed
herself so much because only like a
month Alita sound like a mass text to
our group that she was like I'm coming
home next year with your father to be
ready it was something she'd been
thinking about for a while her children
had moved back to South Africa and her
dream home was almost complete
right literally yes
so she was backing out yeah Josephine is
also mourned by her friends in the UK
like fellow nurse and South African
Cynthia Charles takes long it takes
really long to digest this hoping their
profession is dangerous she says and the
contribution of foreign-born health
workers like mrs. Peter is not always
recognized she was a brave girl for the
mere fact that she actually gave a serve
of herself she could have said no I
don't want to go into covert words but
we are just like that
so we are very brave people and she went
very confidently so Josephine Peter
built a house she'll never live in but
her memory lives on in the people she
loved and they'll keep her close in the
country where she was born John sparks
Sky News Johannesburg